welcome to this video playing master of
puppets you're just a nice handle I
actually and while they go thought about
getting that but it it's kind of it is
taken yeah it's taken and actually like
Metallica a lot back in the day when I
was a little bit younger not that I
dislike them today but as you get older
you can kind of firm have some changes
okay so we have the chip earning Kozlov
hmm what do I do here I do Flay okay
let's play c5 I recently played this
against roost mo didn't didn't end so
well actually I had a good position but
but I'm totally forgetting stuff Bishop
t2 i think Bishop g5 is also an idea
ya hear what can do a forum yeah there's
an old game cuz pair off with black
against Russia Kieran because part of
what a good position ultimately it's I
think we are actually channeling this
game but yeah why does not in a terrible
shape or anything just then i remember
this game yeah bishop gvoice feeling of
course I wonder hmm snide g5 means that
is any good on okay i can i can castle
first forget preventing Bishop g4 one
issue for black he is that it's not so
clear what the light squared Bishop is
going to do if he puts Bishop to e6 I
will sacrifice the exchange at some
point maybe maybe right away so he has
to be quite careful them ok before to f5
okay me play some simple rules here
queen bee three looking at b7 and
possibly just piling up a little bit if
you place root b8 piling up on the
e-file I mean if you please root be
eight and maybe can just stick on the 50
that is surprising i thought 95 would be
just good isn't it I mean you cannot
really take off okay in one of those one
of those typical cases where you say I
cannot play that move and then of course
they play it now and without any big
hesitation yeah age six Hanks you know
this was 11 point that
made me say a cannot take it but yeah
okay let's put everything we have on
this if if you place 97 I'm really
really tempted to sacrifice the exchange
Bishop is 696 rupees sex every 6 that
looks terrible really hmm but is it
winning this is the this is the the
through real real issue is it is winning
is it winning I'm sorry I can also start
with Ruby six rook is six every six
rupee six it looks terrible as well but
keen age seven is kind of kind of
holding Jim
at the end I'm going to do this anyway
one of those exchange sex cannot resist
that okay so what am I going to do rook
takes rook takes yes Quinn d5 James
James Ruby seven it's it's okay
definitely okay but is it the best is it
really the best Queen g3 it's also not
exactly bad Queen g3 King King h7 bishop
f form for Bishop b5 jump I'm spending
far too much time here when I mean
simple nausea probably do suffice I
really don't have to find the the most
I'm super precise way here but know this
probably will be okay King age seven
looks looks almost forced here don't
believe in King f7 or something like
that yeah that I also have my doubts
about if you can survive that it would
be kind of unfair I look rupee six yes
one check rupee six also quite good
section check but ok let's start that I
just have to give a check on on e5 and
it's over or or on the long diagonal
somewhere ok also cannot play look back
a root g8 I mean from the bishop
michaela Bishop f4 it's not possible
time warning hmm
multi5 may be here I yeah let's get cat
get k gets kind of kind of dramatic with
the time you might have 45
and 37 seconds is not not really a lot
right intending Bishop f4
rook t5 maybe check yeah 28 seconds
sometimes my time management is this is
just so far so so outlandish that itit
really don't know what just what to say
28 seconds the position might be
completely winning but yeah but what
what is it was this time black reason I
every scienter which is kind of nice of
him because the position is is wind
completely but help me up to 80 seconds
yeah I takes rook takes he will not
survive this attack has been far too
long here really far too long but kind
of falling asleep yeah okay on the
computer gives in fact the other
sequence as winning which I kind of here
I wasn't sure about this one I hear
Queen g3 okay okay now I get it this is
this is this is really nice yeah and all
the bishops now the bishops are deadly
and pens us hang them okay so what I did
is this winning at least yeah rookie six
given by the comp this is also winning
but the time the time check rookie six
now plus seven yeah the computers of
course merciless as usual yeah I
couldn't I couldn't find a win so I made
those moves they actually still win plus
3 and everything this is just a chance
or hopeless for black that that you can
do those kind of third-rate moves but
here again rookie six does win yeah
there's a move that you're kind of
reluctant to play because of this but
the computer is just giving Queen f7 and
wins even that is not a problem King
edge to
yeah it's kind of unrealistic that is
played in a human blitz game became I
wanted to transfer this to the long
diagonal this is why I when g3 idea
amazingly the position the engine gives
0.6 Queen f6 is kind of holding on and
after that I'm I'm again I'm again
shining with Bishop b5 hmm yeah it was a
somewhat strange way to to play here
like here that's here it's already a bit
tricky I mean you had to reprove before
I think now now you don't have a really
great move b7 is under pressure d 5 is
under pressure and well the the computer
suggest we suggest screen c7 and this is
this position which is really a pawn
with very little of compensation maybe
black can somehow get the bishop there
but that's not great yeah okay how my
time management was absolutely crazy as
usual but otherwise it was pretty ok
thanks for when um thanks for watching